[Music]
look we've all been there right
letting our fear and anger get the best
of us intentionally expanding the
borders of the false world we created
[Music]
mom are you coming down soon mom our
game is freaking out
is she asleep mommy's not sleeping honey
she is just resting her eyes
mom my head feels weird it's like
really noisy i don't like it
resting her eyes
as punishment for my reckless evening i
plan on taking a quarantine style
staycation
a whole day just to myself
that'll show me
[Applause]
what's going on everybody it's born and
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and we just got a preview of
what is going to happen
in episode 7 of one division tomorrow
and it looks like this is probably going
to be the opening scene that we're going
to get for
episode 7. as the first thing it shows
is the sword agents running away from
wanda's hex energy
getting sucked inside of the barrier and
that is the last thing that we saw in
one division episode vi
now it really starts with wanda talking
into the camera and kevin feige said
that we were going to move forward
into a decade of sitcom where they speak
into the camera like modern family
and the office and it looks like we've
hit that episode now wanda says we've
all been there
letting our fear and anger get the best
of us intentionally expanding the
borders of the false world we created
and this is actually the first time
she's really admitted
that she knows what is happening she
knows that this isn't
real and she actually says that her
herself created it however i'm still not
convinced she did because all she
remembers is it happening she doesn't
remember
actually creating it but this shows that
she is now fully aware
of what is happening this isn't real and
she is in control
at least to an extent now it does look
like wanda is kind of beat up about it
kind of upset that she had to resort to
expanding her hex
energy barrier to capture more people
just to save vision
it doesn't seem like she really wanted
to do that and bring more people into
the barrier
then billy and tommy come in and they
say that their game is freaking out and
we can see their controllers start to
kind of digress it looks like their
controllers go from a nintendo switch
controller
to a nintendo gamecube controller and it
digresses all the way to
uno cards in their hands instead of
controllers and it doesn't seem like
wanda is really the one doing this it
seems like the reality is kind of
starting to freak out on its own
possibly implying that wanda doesn't
have a full grip
on what's happening now billy says that
his head feels weird and it's really
noisy and he doesn't like it
now as we just saw in the last episode
the halloween episode billy
and tommy developed their powers and
billy's powers are that he is
telekinetic
and telepathic he has powers just like
his mom so this could be just him
trying to control his powers and get
used to them but we do know that people
who are under control of wanda and
whoever else may be behind this do hear
things
in their head monica rambo said that she
heard wanda in her head after she got
inside of the hex
so it is possible that billy is picking
up on this
kind of reading wanda's mind and other
people's minds as well
now wanda says that she had a reckless
evening
and as her own punishment she's going to
take a quarantine style
staycation she says that she's going to
take a whole day just to herself and
that will show herself
obviously this is a joke as it seems
like wanda just wants time away from
everything that is happening she doesn't
have to worry about controlling
everybody she doesn't have to worry
about any consequences that may come
she just wants a little break and she
wants time to herself but i'm sure after
the ending of the last episode her break
is not going to last that long vision
knows what the outside
looks like now he knows that he can't
survive outside of the energy hex
and he knows that there are sword agents
on the other side and sword agents that
got sucked into the hex
and this could be the episode where we
discover who that mysterious aerospace
engineer is and him and monica break
into the energy hex
so be sure to join me tonight at 3 a.m
eastern time
12 a.m pacific time for my one division
watch party
if you have disney plus we can hit play
at the exact same time and react
together
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos or watch
parties
let me know what you thought about this
clip in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof